STOKING FEARS AND HATRED AND
BIGOTRY.
>> Tammy: JOINING ME NOW IS
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING ME TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I'VE GOT TO ASK YOU, OBVIOUSLY
HORRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES, THE FACT
THAT WE ARE STILL DISCUSSING
THIS ONE NORMALLY TRAGEDIES
BRING AMERICANS, EVERYONE
TOGETHER.
WE HAVE A HISTORY OF DOING THAT.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE.
BUT HERE NOW YOU HAVE THIS
NARRATIVE THAT IS OBSCENE IN
GENERAL.
IT IS CERTAINLY INSULTING TO THE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING
ON?
>> RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LEFT
THAT'S UNWILLING IN AMERICA TO
CONFRONT THE REAL CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE, WHETHER IT'S THE
COLLAPSE OF FATHERHOOD IN OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU LOOK AT THESE MASS SHOOTERS.
VERY RARELY DO YOU SEE A
POSITIVE, PRODUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH A FATHER
FIGURE.
YOU ALSO SEE DARK RECESSES OF
THE INTERNET HARBORING AND
FUMING THIS TYPE OF HATE.
RATHER THAN DEALING WITH THOSE
THINGS, IT'S EASIER FOR THE
POLITICAL LEFT TO SCAPEGOAT THE
PRESIDENT, DEMORALIZE,
DELEGITIMIZE THOSE TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS.
YOU HAVE SEEN A PRESIDENT EAGER
TO COMFORT THOSE IN PAIN AND
ALSO OPEN-MINDED ABOUT WHAT
SOLUTIONS ANYONE WOULD HAVE THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE FREQUENCY OF
THIS VIOLENCE.
IF WE HAVE SEEN ANYTHING FROM
THE SHOOTING AT THE REPUBLICAN
BASEBALL PRACTICE TO THE
ELIZABETH WARREN, ANTIFA
SUPPORTERS, IN DAYTON, THE
PERSON WHO CLAIMED TO HAVE A
RIGHT WING HATEFUL IDEOLOGY IN
EL PASO.
THE EXTREME ELEMENTS OF VIOLENCE
DO NOT HAVE MONOGAMY WITH ANY
ONE AGENDA.
I'M GRATEFUL WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WAS WILLING TO CALL OUT HATE AND
WHO IS TRYING TO PAVE THE WAY TO
A MORE ACCEPTING COUNTRY.
>> Tammy: YOU SEE THAT WITH
THE PICTURES OF THE PRESIDENT
VISITING THE HOSPITAL IN THE
FIRST RESPONDERS, ET CETERA.
THEY ARE THRILLED TO SEE HIM.
THEY ARE THRILLED TO SEE THE
FIRST LADY.
THEY HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT.
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
TRAGEDIES LIKE THIS AND THE
DYNAMICS WERE FACING, THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROACH HAS BEEN
ABOUT SAFETY FOR EVERYONE,
INCLUDING THE MIGRANTS, RIGHT?
OF COURSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THINGS FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS, IT BENEFITS
EVERYONE.
AND YET NOW WE HAVE THIS KIND OF
-- CERTAINLY THE HATRED, BUT YOU
ARE THERE.
WE HAD AN ATTEMPTED
ASSASSINATION OF 23 REPUBLICANS
NOT SO LONG AGO, SERIOUSLY,
ALMOST FATALLY INJURING
STEVE SCALISE.
WE ARE IN THIS HEIGHTENED TIME.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S AN
ALTERNATE REALITY.
MOST AMERICANS I THINK YOU WOULD
AGREE, THEY DON'T BELIEVE WHAT
IT IS THEIR HEARING IN THIS
RHETORIC.
DO YOU THINK IT'S DANGEROUS OR
DO YOU THINK IT'S IMPACTING THE
WAY AMERICANS ARE VIEWING THE
REALITY THAT SURROUNDS ALL OF
US?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW THAT IN TIMES OF POLITICAL
ACTIVITY, PEOPLE CAN CAPITALIZE
ON THESE MOMENTS OF TRAGEDY FOR
THEIR OWN GAIN.
IT'S AWFUL TO SEE THAT, BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SEEN IT UNFOLD
WITH THE WAY THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND SOME DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES HAVE
RESPONDED.
I'VE GOT TO SAY IT'S MARIANNE
WILLIAMSON WHO ACTUALLY CAME
FORWARD AND SAID THERE'S NO
DIRECT CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND THESE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
SHE BELIEVES THERE IS A DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN HOW THE MOON
AND STARS ALIGN AND OUR MOOD.
SHE COULDN'T FIND A DIRECT
CONNECTION.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, HIS
HOSPITALITY BACKGROUND
CONTRIBUTES TO HIS DESIRE TO
BRING WARMTH THE PEOPLE.
HE ALWAYS LIKES PEOPLE TO BE
SORT OF WELCOMED IN HIS
PRESENCE.
>> Tammy: CONGRESSMAN, I THINK
DURING THE CAMPAIGN HE FELL IN
LOVE WITH THE COUNTRY.
I THINK HE GOT TO KNOW US AND HE
SEES THE DAMAGE THAT'S BEEN
DONE.
I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR RESPONSE TO
THE BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT THAT
FORMER FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE IS NOW SUING THE
FBI AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OVER HIS FIRING.
WE KNOW PETER STRZOK IS SUING.
NOW McCABE IS DOING.
HE SAYS HE GOT -- -- THEY GOT
RID OF HIM BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO TRUMP.
MY GUESS IS HE JUST WANTS TO BE
ON TELEVISION FOR SOME
INTERVIEWS.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
EVENT IN CONGRESS SITTING
THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE'S DOING
THIS?
>> IT'S LUDICROUS.
IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP OR THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT ACCUSED
ANDREW MCCABE OF LYING.
IT WAS THE FBI'S OWN
INSPECTOR GENERAL, DEMOCRAT
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA
THAT SAID McCABE LIED THREE
TIMES UNDER OATH ABOUT HIS
ACTIVITY AND IT WAS AN ACTIVITY
THAT WAS GEARED TOWARD USING THE
FBI TO SHAPE PUBLIC OPINION
THROUGH LEAKS, THROUGH THE GREAT
WORK OF BILL BARR AND
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, WERE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FBI
IN THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ART USED TO SHAPE PUBLIC OPINION
BUT RETURNED TO THEIR MISSION OF
INVESTIGATING THE FACTS
AND DOING IT IN A DISPASSIONATE
WAY.
>> Tammy: IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS
THOSE TWO MEN LIKED THE
ATTENTION THEY USED TO GET.
THEY WANT MORE ATTENTION.
AND THEY ARE LOOKING TO GET THAT
ATTENTION ANYWAY THEY POSSIBLY